ce soir on vous amène là où la plupart
de nos enfants n'iront heureusement
jamais dans les centres de la dpj où
vivent des petits enfants éclopés de
notre société
ces couacs vainqueur regarde moi on
travaille ensemble pour que tu te
trompes ou trois ce printemps qu'on nous
a tous marqués suez à 7 en milieu
familial pour i corte dpj on l'a appelée
la petite fille de granby faut pas
oublier qu'avant elle qui a eu le petit
garçon de saguenay combien ce qui fonde
le frapper pour prendre les mesures ne
se sert plus que ça arrive devant ses
horreurs
notre premier réflexe est souvent de
taper sur la dpj est des moments où il
cartonne
est ce que c'est la bonne personne
pourra aider ces gens alors extrêmement
suffrages cette souffrance des enfants
des parents mais aussi des intervenants
qui ont des choix extrêmement difficile
à faire on va vous la montrer ce soir et
vous expliquer comment se prennent les
décisions
vous allez voir que tout n'est pas noir
et blanc
ici marie maude denis bienvenue à
enquête
[Musique]
l'appeler maman je viens par les
enchères risquent au quotidien avec
énormément de décision est-ce que tu as
le nom de cet enfant là c'est pas des
décisions si la vie d'enfants
sabine et est au rendez vous
ces soupes quand on arrive sur une scène
comme saubens on n'a pas le temps de
réfléchir à ce que parce qu'on a appris
à l'université on agit 3 peut-être parce
qu'on a envie des choses
hackett rossi a probablement tout a
foiré du début à la fin
[Musique]
du début à la fin
nous avons suivi presque toutes les
étapes d intervention de la dpj deux
semaines au saguenay pour mieux
comprendre le travail des intervenants
et la détresse de leurs clients fait des
idées encore je sais pas qu'un sort à sa
sortie
quand je vais avoir des nouvelles je
suis au portant de l'argent n'est pas
soi comment tu vis avec ça
depuis la peine comme l'autre fois
la peine et l'incertitude ça fait partie
de la vie de jesse il a connu quatre
familles cinq en comptant la sienne
émilie tremblay et sa travailleuse
sociale et son chauffeur aussi parfois
comment ça a été deux semaines au chalet
ou de mon échec de ta propre canapa
chatoie que ses autres que l'on donné
c'est un jeune homme je viens al fassil
d' approche
il ya beaucoup de capacité à protéger
lui-même côté gonnot dire s'il ya des
situations qui boit et mais il faut être
capable de nommer ces choses aujourd'hui
jesse a besoin de parler car sa dernière
visite à la maison a mal tourné un gros
conflit lié avec une femme très proche
de sa mère juste pour que cette fois
encore l'homme à faire la chicane elle
souhaite s'excuser auprès de toi sur
comment ça s'est passé la dernière fois
à l'oral c'est qu'un ça c'est qu'il ya
eu beaucoup de chemin depuis que tu as
aimé ça vous ferait aussi à ton frère
aussi affecté je pense que tout le monde
allait avoir besoin de revenir sur soit
est tous d'accord
jesse a un petit frère mais ils sont
placés dans deux familles différentes
on manque de familles d'accueil au
saguenay comme ailleurs
jesse n'a pas vu alex depuis un mois la
famille de son frère accepte de le
recevoir pour la nuit a eu deux ils
totalisent huit familles différentes
et ça ça laisse des traces mais c'est 1
2 et à chaque fois c'est de refaire
confiance de se demander est ce que
cette vertueuse je m'attache fait
confiance mais ce qu'elle va demeurer là
pour voir cette nouvelle personne dedans
c'est très difficile pour eux la
dernière famille d'accueil de jesse a dû
fermer ses portes et emilie a senti
qu'il commençait à s'éteindre
c'est vraiment la dernière qui a été la
plus difficile j'avais l'impression un
peu qu'ils avaient bien mélanger prise
de drogue à quoi bon l'autre s'ils
étaient vraiment découragé mais il a été
capable de trouver ses repères quand
même pu s'adapter puis bien fonctionné
depuis un an
ça colle avec sa nouvelle famille et
jesse à des projets khaliah ali
c'est belfort samedi qui s'installe qui
est bien c'est qu'il se projette dans
l'avenir aussi à cet endroit là c'est ta
famille d'accueil enfin on semble avoir
trouvé la bonne famille pour jesse mais
pourra-t-il y rester ou voudra-t-il
retourner chez sa mère le lien familial
qui les unit est profond sa mère a déjà
fait son choix mais ça geci ne le sait
pas encore
dans l'institution où il réside
zachary lui c'est qu'il ne retournera
jamais vivre chez sa maman on le lui a
annoncé la semaine dernière ont ils
annoncé cette nouvelle loi puis il me
parlait complètement de faire d'autres
choses on parlait de sa collation une
part l'est où il disait qu'il ne voulait
plus parler qu'on se termine et qu'on ne
parlait plus ensemble
c'est du denim que c'est une forme de
déni de sa force il veut pas l'entendre
mais on n'est pas prendre lui on n'est
pas prêt west ham en tentant depuis un
an
zachary vie dans un centre de
réadaptation pour les enfants de 6 à 12
ans ceux pour qui on ne trouve pas
facilement de famille parce que pour eux
mêmes la douche c'est compliqué c'est ce
même toit
[Musique]
faut lui rappeler la voiture en général
il faut lui il faut s'assurer aussi même
si la colère cette route sun la fausse
assuré que soit pas en train de faire
d'autres choses que cette route seniors
qui soit pas en train de de faire un
mauvais coup de mou y est son linge de
mettre de l'eau un peu partout de faire
des choses comme ça martin bresson et
éducateur spécialisé
il s'occupe de zacharie huit ans presque
à temps plein est à toi sur ton lit pour
le faire c'est que je choisis comme je
précède bouger la jambe était qu'on veut
il faut de la patience et de la
constance
ici les éducateurs pose toujours les
mêmes questions
de la même façon enfin bellemans fait
fait que reprendre le fameux le mans moi
ça c'est ma demain avec cas ok à moins
de bell demain fait moins de demain le
langage est constant comme l'obligation
pour les enfants de se remettre en
question je respecte les interventions
je dépends des quotas
ça c'est pour mon ancien tableau mais ce
qui marche avec les autres ne fonctionne
pas nécessairement avec zachary et son
tempérament explosif sa semaine encore
plein conte comportement travail et
qu'on le voit là dedans au travatan
tableau tiens regarde ce que martèle
réparer c'est un système de récompenses
personnalisé pour zachary basés sur les
personnages de l'émission patrouille
deuxième objectif pour sa voix de faire
un bon déjeuner beau temps douche et
puis une belle occupation le matin puis
surtout pas d'heure exactement
tu écoutes les conseils puis surtout il
ya pas deux et puis après ça y est la
collation et le coucher
si tout va bien ça et surtout y'a pas de
parfaits est-ce que ce parce que ça peut
marcher mais zachary décide qu'il veut
ces récompenses tout de suite avant
d'avoir atteint ses objectifs
[Musique]
non chatah campagne je ne confonds pas
les cas pas recroiser salaces marseille
vas-y
oui oui
des sites web qu'est
est ce qu'on est capable de faire tomber
de menottes qui va tourner sur plancher
et bien régis line up ce qui est choisie
sera versée qu'en chambre simone axe
faut travailler certaines choses au
contraire les délais on travail l'attend
en même temps on a d'abord coup mais
c'est pas tout il faut pas tout temps
tout adapté donc lui faut faire
travailler notre jeune dans ce sens le
faire travailler
mais pour l'année où le but principal
c'est que soit on arrive à un niveau de
fonctionnalité normale soit en mesure
d'aller à l'école de développer des
relations de se développer lui-même en
tant que personne et puis d'être en
sécurité
la base on vise la base quelques orages
engendrent une fois cette base atteinte
il s'agira de trouver la famille qui
pourra l'accueillir
c'est un jeune qui est charmant mais
c'est un jeune qui a besoin d'une
supervision constante quel genre de
famille d'accueil peut s'occuper de
l'enfant comme sociale moi je reste
confiant qu'on va trouver parce que jc
quand un jour on va essayer de sortir un
jour un jour on va c'est de sortir d'ici
passons par une marche
en attendant la vie des enfants continue
au centre d'hébergement
zachary compose avec un nouvel ami qui
lui fait un peu d'ombré le droit et l
avant toi ok mais je dois faire ça
pendant que juste à côté des parents se
battent pour conserver la garde de leurs
enfants
[Musique]
toute la gamme et la halle aux grains
depuis la dernière fois
voici emile il se présente à la dpj en
compagnie de son papa de sa belle maman
et de sa toute nouvelle demi soeur la
mère biologique des 1000 n'est pas dans
la pièce et la de graves problèmes de
drogue et c'est son père qui s'en occupe
avec sa nouvelle conjointe sauf que le
père a vacillé récemment il faut donc
revoir les conditions de garde avec
leurs travailleuses sociales justin
rousseau et la réviseurs valérie pilote
la gestion des émotions c'est quelque
chose qui est facile pour vous tout le
temps puis dans un corps d'où ce qu'il
ya des facteurs de stress qui viennent
se rajouter ben là ça peut faire des
débordements c'est un peu ce qui est
arrivé mais là vraiment un gros
débordement un qui a fait que il ya
quand même eu des impacts
le débordement est survenu pendant
l'accouchement de sa compagne justine a
dû forcer le père a quitté la maison
pour 48 heures il avait menacé des
policiers aient recommencé à consommer
mon stage c'est légal mais c'est pas une
question de légal pour l'actrice et les
gains et puis des fois on va retenir un
problème de consommation d'alcool comme
un motif de compromission à cause des
impacts [ __ ] dans la vie mais c'est
pas ça tous les jours
après vingt minutes de déni de la part
du père justin met les points sur les i
en trouve pour la consommation cocagne
en dur un bon les pilotes de grossesse
sa consommation est un sujet sensible
il est lui même un ancien enfants de la
dpj
on le sait que c'est un épisode mais il
reste que ça fait partie de l'ensemble
des facteurs de risque
exactement on vole de mains en fait il
n'a pas nié sa consommation de cocaïne
et ça joue en sa faveur
loin des gros facteur de protection
contexte et par endosser la transparence
dit vous allez vous l'avez vu ce sont
des gens très très transparent sur tout
le temps comme ceux ci arrive des choses
est bon de fac dans le fond si on résume
les par un bond du défunt nouveau mais
pour nous ça change pas ça change pas le
fait qu'on veut qu'il reste avec vous
nous on vous reconnaît des compétences
malgré ce qui est arrivé
le père accepte finalement d'être suivie
en toxicomanie et la dpj demeurera dans
leur vie pendant plusieurs mois
mais les enfants resteront avec le
couple au grand soulagement de la
nouvelle maman qui a tissé des liens
très forts avec son beau fils vous
n'êtes pas sa mère biologique
ça m'a dit mais nous comme effet j on a
regardé c'est qui les personnes signifie
quoi pour un enfant c'est une personne
jusqu'à thibodeau l'au delà de la
biologie loge est embarrassée parce que
je faisons cinq jeunes travailler c'est
bien des dossiers comme celui là justin
en 1 22
elle devrait en avoir un maximum de 16
il ya des moments où ils ont en question
nous demandons est ce que je fais les
bonnes choses
est ce que est ce que c'est la bonne
personne pour aider ces gens à l'eau
extrêmement ce frein c'est de la
souffrance au quotidien fait des fois où
il s'est tapé sur les épaules comme
émilie tremblay justin travail en
application des mesures là où on suit
les familles à long terme le secteur
réputé le plus dur et le plus exigeant
fait on
les gens sont submergés fait pied quand
on compare ap elle travaille à la dpg
depuis trois ans seulement
dès le début sans formation terrain sans
mentorat la pile de dossiers l'attendait
depuis l'app il s'alourdit et la
pression aussi plus grande part c'est
quoi ben c'est clair c'est qu'il n'y
arrive quelque chose en invitant des
enfants que je côtoie que j'accompagne
karim de quoi non l'avis des parents
aussi fait ce qu'on s'attache aux gens
qu'on rencontre une pression que ressent
aussi sa consoeur emilie c'est moi quand
j'ai commencé en protection une de mes
collègues qui m'avait dit quand tu pars
à 4h30 propre station que toutes ces
enfants lors des 22 que j'ai sont en
sécurité et que
c'est un doute qu'un des enfants dans
les potes ne peut pas partir pour tout
assure que ses enfants soient en
sécurité aujourd'hui sa collègue justin
va superviser une visite à l'appartement
d'une maman son fils de deux ans et
placée en famille d'accueil
c'est une maxi sorte la grèce conjugue à
la consommation parce qu'elle voulait
garder son bébé le fait une rechute
important de consommation scholes
toxiques qui polluent qu'on intervient
sur les lieux en urgence puis qu'on
sorte la marre de ce milieu où donc on
vient ici tout est correct puis aussi
tranquillement posé de sa route ait
aussi monstre qu'est ce qui se vend
mieux que mamadou bah non c'est mon
préféré ça non c'est le deuxième
placement de tommy hill et en famille
d'accueil depuis quatre mois
enfant qui est en colère citez moi c'est
ce que je vois la différence entre bon
le petit coco qui connaît sa mère tu
obtiens équipe réfugié dans ses bras ah
non non je n'ai pas bu bon c'est clair
que ça perturbe l'attachement que la
relation entre l'enfant notamment est ce
que c'est les choses qui peuvent se
rebâtir puis il se reconstruire oui
c'est pas tout perdu 1000 actuellement
clairement il ya des enjeux pour cet
enfant là qu'il faut considérer qu'elle
est le mobile
l'enjeu numéro un pour justin ce sont
les possibilités de rechute de la mer et
donc d'un autre classement pour tomi on
n'est pas tout à fait encore à la
dernière chance mais on est pas loin
ben oui parce que c'est sûr que c'est
caen qui ont cumulé mauvaise expérience
que ça devient en guimaëc chronique
discuter des personnes là ne veut pas la
juger mais nous si on commence à perdre
confiance puis perd espoir aussi que ça
pourrait fonctionner
la mère de tommy veut le retrouver la
plupart des mamans dans cette situation
veulent retrouver leurs enfants mais pas
tout le temps j'ai juste réalisé que ce
tapage très bonne personne tant est que
les enfants ont besoin devient besoins
d'haïti s'est pendu à l'instar justement
ça fait déjà trois semaines que jesse
est allé visiter son frère dans sa
famille d'accueil qui ne déclarent pas
du club
ça fait bizarre soir aujourd'hui la mère
des deux garçons rencontrés me lie à son
bureau
maman à un nouvel appartement ses fils
lui ont rendu visite récemment mais il
n'y a pas de chambres pour eux quand son
logement vient de poser des questions
sur le fait que avec notre armée ou bien
vu quelqu'un avec moi car sa décision
est prise ses deux fils ne reviendront
pas ils resteront chacun dans leur
famille d'accueil jusqu'à l'âge de 18
ans
je concède que je sais que leur mère a
l'habitude des conjoints violents et de
l'instabilité du à la consommation elle
accepte maintenant que se défaire de ce
bagage sera trop long pour ses fils puis
ces deux là où on s'y rend compte que
ces pots que moi je crois capable de lui
offrir ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont
réellement besoin
la dernière étape la plus difficile sera
d'annoncer la nouvelle aux garçons parce
que je vous suggère comme objectif c'est
qu'on prévoit une rencontre où vous
allez dire aux enfants je me sens pas
capable de vous reprendre je vous permet
d'être bien famille d'accueil puis en
clair c'est qu'on dise demain ça va être
votre projet pour jusqu'à vos 18 ans en
fait il qu'on fasse on a vécu à la
dernière rencontre que dix minutes j'ai
pris une décision juste a pris le chemin
des studios et colmar chômage technique
qu'elle y aller et je veux m'acheter un
kayak
oui mais la star et x projet tintin il
voit l'été prochain parce qu'ils ont à
faire avec ma famille d'accueil
et c'est peut-être que lui aussi ça va
peut-être plus confirmés de dire qu'il
va se voir imputer ce à long terme si je
pense que c'est fait un petit peu plus à
l'idée que soulagement les larmes
coulent
car leur mère aussi doit se faire à
l'idée c'est pour ça que la cette
rencontre est importante mais en même
temps moi je vous soyez prêtes pour le
fan je dois vous bousculer la nouère ses
sauces il lui reste quelques semaines
pour trouver les mots
[Musique]
c'est le retour de l'école au centre de
réadaptation comme à la maison
on prend la collation cinq morts qu'on
regarde ton agenda on ouvre et on signe
les agendas scolaires
beau travail en classe chiffres vraiment
fier de toi très bien en éducation mais
ça on le mieux super journée
yes bravo fasse sourire de se démarquer
brise une pelle qu'il trouve au passage
trois petits points
bien en place par comme à la maison aux
joues avec les amis après le souper
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais le décor lui n'a rien à voir avec
la maison des murs en béton des meubles
vissé au plancher et des portes
verrouillable de l'extérieur questions
de sécurité selon l'éducateur mathieu
massage à 8 à 10 ans oui en haut niveau
des frustrations de claquages de porte
des coups dans le mur
c'est de la violence en est des gens qui
sont très explosif fiction on arrête de
me dodji pas comment on voit communément
mais ça serait sûrement brisé c'est sûr
que c'est pas idéal c'est pas un milieu
familial
mais ce milieu ce qui est sécurité à
chalon vient des interventions que les
internats critique y travaillent
c'est un milieu de vie mais c'est pour
la vraie vie restant à faire benjamin 8
ans est un des derniers arrivés se fait
d'avoir au dessus en fait on va
commencer je vais voir ken macha
collation pour façon à l'école
il n'a pas de problème et il s'entend
bien avec les autres garçons mais il est
un produit de son milieu familial
au départ on avait un paquet qui fasse
de la violence à la maison sauf que lyon
avait retiré le père du milieu et c'est
ce que probable que les méthodes
éducatives super parce que c'est moi le
mot mood cessé de luxe hors terre j'ai
l'impression qu'ils avaient pas le droit
de pleurer
j'ai l'impression qu'ils soient
d'aquitaine bébé beaucoup parce que
c'est lui qu'il nomme l'aï dit c'est mon
patrimoine car je peux pas comparer le
jeu marrant c'est drôle c'est lui qui va
nous dire un mot faut que j'améliore mon
langage ou j'améliore ma violence
je fais la violence c'est inutile ça il
y en a eu les équipes d'allianz
d'ailleurs en ce moment déjà mais réagit
mal à l'autorité féminine celle de sa
mère et des éducatrices
il va travailler là-dessus au centre
pendant deux mois
peut-être plus
la collation qu'est ya un mois
bonojean terme mais quand arrive le soir
pourquoi j'ai raté aussi jouer à tout le
monde à sa mère lui manque
il est ici depuis un mois et il a vu
plusieurs gars sont retournés à la
maison mais pas lui
tu l'as vu ce qu'ils retournent chez eux
qui s'attendraient à sauter de toit de
votre nez chez toi ça te fait pas oui
c'est normal c'est quoi qui inquiète
regarde moi on travaille en simple pour
que tu rentres chez toi maman travaille
de son côté aussi fort bientôt on pourra
avoir des contacts avec maman les tons
pour avoir des contacts avec ma main
puis on va travailler le mamad d'âge
alain éducatrice qui travaillaient tous
le savez j'avais une travailleuse
sociale travaille elle aussi ton par les
gens aussi avec la tout le monde
travaille fort tu travailles des
objectifs à terme il y aurait beaucoup
de politesse beaucoup aussi le respect
d'intervention avec les filles c'était
difficile
belle avec marrant ça va être pareil
comportement des dauphins
quand tu sois chez elle c'est kiki voire
méprisé qui va faire les interventions
scéniques modeste' les règles la routine
martin il regarde pour un contrat type
maman prochainement
ok tu es conscient leur sang des trains
plus abonnement ratant son hockey - deux
garçons à dos mais d'ici un mois on
saura si les efforts de benjamin et sa
maman ont remporté fruits et s'il pourra
retourner chez lui
[Musique]
le centre de réadaptation c'est un peu
le cul de sac
le dernier recours des enfants en
détresse de la dpj réception des six
allemands tandis que le bureau de
christine bard on en est la porte
d'entrée
le nouveau conjoint s'appelle comme un
monsieur vous avez été témoin de saut
vous avez entendu dire c'est elle qui
vous répond si vous êtes enseignant
policiers ou simples citoyens et que la
situation d'un enfant vous inquiète
elle et son équipe reçoivent une
centaine de signalements par semaine
qu'est ce qu'on sait s'il y avait des
plaintes policière ou des choses comme
ça là par rapport à la consommation de
la mer ça l'amène à quel état quant à
consomme sa dépression c'est suite à
l'accouchement de le bbc du départ axant
sa part et vous brisez les objets en
votre présence d c'est de la violence
qui est ce qu on sait la force qu'elle a
utilisé ce qu'il y avait des marques
une caresse qui démarre là on gère du
risque au quotidien avec énormément de
fusion c'est dans une journée on en
prendre la décision là on en prend
beaucoup pis c'est pas des décisions
c'est la vie d'enfants
rapidement elle doit déterminer le
niveau d'urgence
le code un bel os et une intervention
immédiate
on a un enfant qui est très très très
vulnérable le code 2 c'est que ça
nécessite d'enfants une intervention
dans le 24 heures puis un code 3 baissé
dans les quelques jours ces deux à trois
jours mais il n'y a pas de notion de
danger mais de preuves
lundi matin un premier code 1 de la
semaine on un signalement qui est entré
en fin de semaine pour un enfant en bas
de deux ans qui ont été amenés en centre
hospitalier intoxiqué au cannabis dans
ses colonnes au delà du cannabis qui
était qui étaient présents dans
l'estomac fait que ça laisse quand même
croire que l'enfant pourra en avoir
ingéré de quelle manière ce jeu c'est
pour par exemple nous sommes au début du
processus et christina besoin d'en
savoir plus elle appelle d'abord à
l'hôpital puis est arrivé quand
exactement dr bouchard à l'hôpital
vendredi
ok puis dans le fond est en place
endormi peut être dans quel état sont
réveillés samedi matin claude halfon les
analyses c'est clair qu'il y avait donc
urines l'estomac puis dans le sang est
ce que vous pensez pouvoir le garder
l'enfant à l'hôpital jusqu'à temps que
l'évaluation prennent le relais
excellent au revoir l'entourage du père
le confirme c'est un consommateur de
cannabis et l'enfant étaient avec lui
mais il reste encore beaucoup de
questions est ce que c'est de la
négligence est ce que c'est parce que le
parent le site rennais de la
consommation est ce que c'est réellement
lui un gros boulot d'informations qu'on
apprenait ferme
on va aller présenter la situation sans
surprise le signalement sera retenue ne
reste qu'à déterminer le motif précis et
le code de priorité c'est la
surveillance parce que à le hac s'est
visiblement ça traînait à sa porte à
dix-huit mois donc surveillance toxico
pas parfait excellent est-ce que
oui on va envoyer le code 1 puis qu'on
regarde avec le parc des mois incluent
l'opra christine a presque fini son bout
dans kate elle répond maintenant aux
questions du ssp un logiciel censé
l'aider à traiter le signalement
l'efficacité du ssp n'a jamais été
reconnu ni même évalué mais il est
obligatoire dans toutes les dpj du
québec obligatoire est inutile selon la
travailleuse sociale
nancy poulin ans instinct complètement
perdu ça n'a aucune valeur ajoutée dans
la pratique professionnelle de plusieurs
intervenants
le logiciel propose des choix de réponse
et il faut cocher quelque chose même si
la vraie réponse n'est pas dans les
choix souvent un fossé
notre destin est prise avant de le
compléter avec certaines choses parce
que c'est obligé mais on le fait mais ma
décision est déjà prise
moi et si les logiciels n'arrivent pas à
la même décision que la travailleuse
sociale
mais dans ce temps là on essaie de de
faire en sorte que la réponse à nos
questions arrivent à la bande
d'étudiants vous retournez dans le
logiciel maemo modifier vos réponses
jusqu'à temps que la réponse soit la
même que la que la vôtre sosthène
possibilité dans la sphère du bébé
intoxiqués
le logiciel et les professionnels sont
d'accord mais ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas après la pause vous allez voir que
ce logiciel ssp a été au coeur d'une
tragédie qui a tout changé à saguenay
[Musique]
notamment nous a mis un gros soleil dans
notre vieillesse moi et ma blonde
ce périphérique malraux sartre matin
thomas audet n'avait pas encore deux ans
lorsqu'il est mort dans des
circonstances nébuleuses
c'était en 2016 et ses quatre
grands-parents émerge à peine on était
comme jamais vous explique le maire
on est dans un vase clos trois ans et
demi plus tard on ne sait pas exactement
qui a fait quoi
selon nos sources le dossier d' enquête
de la police serait sur le point d'être
transmis au procureur
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que thomas
était chez sa mère et son nouveau
conjoint le jour de sa mort ce qu'on
sait surtout c'est qu'un mois auparavant
la dpj avait reçu un signalement on ne
peut pas échapper un enfin quand il ya
eu un signalement et dont 51 xiam un
fait le suivi du personnel de la dpj a
confirmé que thomas avait été blessé
plusieurs fois sur plusieurs mois
sans surprise le signalement est retenue
c'est le motif qui étonne négligences
sur le plan éducatif essentiellement un
problème de surveillance ben voyons dont
une fracture à la jambe lacération à
l'oreille une main pratiquement quand
c'est une lente un père faure est coupée
c'est un problème et éducationnel des
surveillants problème mais deux
surveillants nous avons obtenu en
exclusivité le rapport de la commission
des droits de la personne sur la mort de
thomas audet il est formel le
signalement aurait dû être classé comme
un abus physiques plutôt qu'une
négligence sur le plan éducatif une
erreur grave qui en a entraîné une autre
tout aussi grave le cas de tôle en
éclats ces codes 300 danger immédiat au
lieu de code un intervention immédiate
son dossier se retrouve donc sous la
pile est ce que l'intrus mais pas
capable de porter un jugement suffisant
suffisamment précis pour j
un peu et dans vos rues pour la vie de
cet enfant ne s'appelle dangereux pour
la santé de son enfant dont on le sait a
lu les gros mais quel être humain a
commis cette erreur là peut-être aucun
la commission blâme surtout le logiciel
le fameux ssp et c'est incohérente
le rapport du logiciel décrit d'abord la
vulnérabilité extrême de thomas et au
final le logiciel conclut pourtant à sa
vulnérabilité très faible une
contradiction manifeste qui a en partie
justifié le fameux code 3 sans danger
immédiat un code 3 qui aurait dû être
évalués en douze jours maximum
mais après 23 jours thomas n'avait pas
encore été rencontré par une
travailleuse sociale
il est mort le 18 juin 2016 à l'âge de
22 mois
[Musique]
nancy poulin l'a su avant tout le monde
car à l'époque elle dirigeait le
syndicat je m'en souviens encore c'est
un matin j'ai été convoqué par la
direction générale dans son bureau pied
annoncé qu'un en fait j'étais dans cet
état là je pleure je me levais je peux
pas croire que ça fait cinq ans qu'on
dit qu'ils vont arriver un drame le
drame est survenu dans un contexte de
compressions et de fusion et il a
ébranlé tout le saguenay comme la
tragédie de granby se courait le québec
tout entier
trois ans plus tard tout d'un coup c'est
important d'ajouter des ressources
supplémentaires de diminuer de
d'attendre parce que l'on savait
jusqu'où ça pourra aller d'avoir des
listes d'attentes en protection un
jeûneur ça peut nous emmener jusqu'à des
deux ça a tout d'un coup ça l'important
le style sera à l'époque la ministre de
la protection de la jeunesse lucie
charlebois avait affirmé que la dpj
avaient toutes les ressources
nécessaires dans le budget
mais la région n'avait pas tout ce qu'il
fallait il a fallu débloquer 2 millions
à même le budget du sinus pour créer 25
postes afin de réduire les listes
d'attentes
selon nos calculs le saguenay a
maintenant le plus bas pourcentage de
dossiers en attente
au québec une décision locale assumer
nous l'an passé on a déjà ouvert 25
postes avant même d'avoir de l'argent en
plus on avait de surcroît dernièrement
et l'on voudrait engager des gens on a
fait des choix au départ de d'autres
choix de notre option pour répondre aux
besoins des enfants
mais la dpj avait-elle vraiment le choix
dans un deuxième rapport dévastateur
la commission des droits de la personne
avait souligné de graves lacunes dans
son fonctionnement dont le fameux
logiciel ssp qui ne doit pas se
substituer au jugement des
professionnels le manque de formation et
une directrice sans aucune expérience en
protection de la jeunesse
la nouvelle directrice a fait toute sa
carrière à la dpj
elle l'admet les conclusions de la
commission ont forcé des changements
qu'est-ce que vous avez chargé les
processus beaucoup processus ont été
revus on a offert une formation spéciale
pour toutes nos personnes à réception et
traitement des signalements d'avoir la
même compréhension de la protection de
la jeunesse
une situation qui est compromise vers ce
nom qui ne l'est pas les articles de loi
les codes de priorité c'est vraiment
tout a été refait là dessus ce qui n'a
pas été refait c'est le ssp trois ans
après le drame
le ministère de la santé n'a toujours
pas procédé à la révision du logiciel
comme le recommandait pourtant la
commission des droits de la personne
mais après la tragédie granby le
ministère a rapidement compris qu'il
fallait investir
j'annonce aujourd'hui que nous allons
injecter un montant de 47 millions de
dollars pour consolider les services en
protection de la jeunesse au québec
quand c'est arrivé le lit l'histoire de
green bay on avait crû de 3,2 pouces et
on aux véhicules dès maintenant les
mêmes émotions les mêmes émotions et un
constat ce qui a changé au saguenay ne
semblent pas avoir d'effet ailleurs faux
pas c'est que ce qui avait été écrit est
sorti sur la façon de faire avec thomas
allait s'appliquer à l'ensemble de la
dpj
pourquoi ça c'est parfait ils sont
aperçus qu'il y avait des lacunes ici si
tu as le même organisme dans 12 régions
du québec soit dry pause soit les
questions est ce que le même problème se
présente
aion en attendant le résultat de la
poursuite que les grands parents ont
déposé contre la dpj andré simard tente
sans est arrivé de voir plus loin que
son chagrin espagne que ça marcherait
qu'un profond pour les enfants
du futur hockey et je me dis dans les
trois dernières années
peut-être quand on menace aubépins deux
poumons saison comme une petite
consolation mais à la fin une grande
consommation
il est plus lentement sont plus
l'allemagne au retour on conclut notre
enquête en vous donnant des nouvelles de
tout le monde
[Musique]
j'aurais bien ouais c'est ça ou la mère
de justin n'a pas encore trouvé la force
d'annoncer à ses fils qu'ils resteront
en famille d'accueil
il continue de se voir en famille
environ une fois par mois
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle rechute pour la mère
du petit ami elle ne peut plus recevoir
son fils à la maison
tommy lavoie maintenant dans les bureaux
du centre jeunesse
zachary lui se cherche toujours une
famille d'accueil
son séjour au centre de réadaptation et
prolongé d'au moins six mois c'est quoi
ton coeur benjamin n'aura finalement pas
pu l'éviter
cette semaine il est entré en famille
d'accueil il avait atteint ses objectifs
et réduit sa violence la mère de
benjamin est encore trop fragile pour le
reprendre
11 3-20 3 ans auront été suffisants pour
justine elle vient de quitter la
protection de la jeunesse pour terminer
sa maîtrise et travailler avec les
jeunes contrevenants
quant à la poursuite des grands parents
de thomas audet elle suit son cours en
terminant merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
permis d'entrer dans leur intimité qui
ont rendu ce reportage possible on
espère qui vous a touché on dans le tout
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
est revenu nous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]